ciao ragazzi benvenuti a una puntata di
cucina buttata oggi faremo una ricetta
che ha spopolato su youtube un dolce da
15 milioni di visualizzazioni un dolce
che ha dentro la banana vabbè dai
andiamo a fast e 15 chiusa
[Musica]
se ho tutto molto chiaro il procedimento
è abbastanza semplice questa è una cosa
importante queste mani preparano una
torta con un tot numero di ingredienti
che secondo me sono una presa per il
culo perché a un certo punto si
moltiplicano nel piatto quindi propongo
direttamente di raddoppiarle anche
perché loro hanno uno stampo da 22 cm
predator ha portato una bacinella così
per cui sappiate che se vorrete fare
questa torta in uno stampo piccolo dove
rete dimezzare i colloqui se dovrete
fare in uno stampo un po più grande
invece seguite le mie nel dubbio seguite
le mie punto bisogna tagliare le banane
giustozzi cosa che sei in grado di fare
no non solitamente non le mangio per
quelle che una volta volevo fare i
gelati quelli più sani sono quelli fatti
con le banane congelate poi quando
l'aver tritare col col cioccolato
praticamente poi divenne questa crema e
congelate così cioè che quando le
occhiate fuori non potevo sbucciarle
arriva del mio dice casa aprono il coso
del freezer e beccano banane congelate
così riguardo ne fanno scusa ma queste
io ho capito dirgli no e per fare il
gelato ok posso provare un gioco vai
ogni volta che parliamo
bellissimo così anche nei commenti
allora però non cioè no la gente
volgarità ma se volete riesco a farci
entrare tutto questo gioco è bellissima
ragazzi voglio continuare ragazzi mi
raccomando metteteci un bel pollice in
su a questo a questo video
pensavo parla di banane allora intanto
direi di partire un po di burro sciolto
dicono che a palermo per fare nella fuci
ria tipo pane e panelle sputino nella
pentola per vedere se c'è tipo calda non
per lubrificare perché vedete calda
totalizzando 80 di zucchero ma tu sei
certo di caramellizzazione se tu lo
sbatti tanto a volte rischia di
schiumare mai di fare a schiuma
questa marisa che tu mi hai dato si sta
sciogliendo
perchè calda e non è fatta per cuocere
questa
bisogna stare attenti ragazzi se lo
tieni troppo dopo fuma buttiamoci subito
dentro la banana
andiamo a caramellare per 5 minuti una
roba molto molto svelto e veloce ok ha
posto due uova
apriamo le che adesso fondamentale con
una frusta andiamo a sbatterle
ok aggiungiamo un po di zucchero mentre
sbatto un
chiaro montiamo lo per bene perché
adesso un po più scuro quindi lo andiamo
a sbiancare
allora aggiungo vanillina e vado avanti
starkey nell'unica difficoltà e che
dovunque al braccio di fa male negli
intanto di cambiare mano a ambidestro
quindi 12 5 a 12 schizzi e arrivati
terzo round sbatto indomabile mi aiuto
con dell'olio al volo qua un botto g di
lievito da aggiungere alla farina uniamo
prima la parte secca che poi
aggiungeremo a quella umida e meglio per
lubrificare ma per le due cose vanno un
pochino a braccetto bisogna riconoscere
una cosa sta ricetta che na cazzata
effettivamente fa l'ora butto sul piano
quindi lo sbatto sopra il tavolo un
pochino e mi metto a lavorarlo con le
mani con i brividi a volte non si fermi
si potesse più simile al mahmood proprio
affare blanco ha pertanto
questa città iscriverti al buio
no ragazzi bianco cioè la nuova danza
invece cazzo noi adesso è fondamentale
dobbiamo prendere l'impasto e dividerlo
in due terzi da una parte e un terzo
dall'altro questo lo mettiamo nella
pellicola e lo buttiamo subito in
freezer quando mettete una casa in
freezer piccolo suggerimento invece di
metterlo a paletta in freezer lo
appiattite e quindi lo vedrete in
composta darà molta più superficie per
raffreddarsi più velocemente ma nel
freezer per 10 minuti un po di farina
stendiamo a ragazzi mi raccomando
mattarelli se gli usa the bells i lunghi
e larghi ok che vi aiutano a stendere
meglio sto andando anche piano per
riuscire ad avere un controllo maggiore
sulle spinte adesso pigliamo una teglia
che abbiamo foderato della carta amt
mentina letto
adesso vado a tagliarla ea renderla
omogenea ovunque forse la mia frolla
migliore adesso inutile un cucchiaio
dobbiamo raddoppiarlo quindi andremo a
metterci quanto due cucchiai bravissimi
pre del cucchiaio e andate a prendere la
nutella o un cucchiaio a questo vale per
due cucchiai vedevo come si spalma ma il
vincolo perché non vuole entrare perché
a lui ti bloccano le porte semiaperte
16 dentro con la testa vuol dire a è una
testa enorme e come il parto che basta
che veda la banana
bisogna ammettere nostre la scena ma le
posso dire anche a me raga quando tu ti
prendi il tempo per fare le cose bene
non importa dove le fai ma vengono bene
ed è bello venire bene
vediamo l'ultimo pezzo vediamo se è
diventato bello duro andiamo con una
grattugia a grattugiando all'interno dei
buchi più larghi che finora
non si è vero ragazzi non sono mai stato
così orgoglioso di un dolce l'ho fatto
adesso la mettiamo a 180 gradi forno
statico per 25 30 minuti e preghiamo
gesù facciamo così 25 metri ci vediamo
qui vai vai turgido portato ruby dino
molto molto caldo cacciano la verità e
tiro fuori se mi si rompe so cazzi dove
infilarlo sotto e tirarlo fuori dal buco
aspetta che devo passare dal buco senza
toccarlo perché sennò
la guarda che se tu la guardi bene in
realtà cela delle fighette si più bella
lo zucchero appello ragazzo era meglio
in cucina puntata certo che giorno
nefasto per tecnici cin cin cin
ti piace la banana lo si contrae la
lente di mary cabala non chiuderla e
perfetto per me sono contento allora che
se tu sei voluto assaggiare adesso anche
statistica fortunata di misura già mi
faccio solo esperimento dei neonati o
coin purse bel morso e dal parere parere
per bene a merda capisci capisci
e voi ragazzi prima di salutarci che tim
siete la banana vi piace oppure no nei
dolci ci vediamo alla prossima ciao ciao
[Applauso]
[Musica]